en el vídeo sobre estructuras de enlace
línea empezamos con esta estructura de
ley de louis verdad empezamos con esta
estructura de louis y le mostré cómo
convertir esta estructura de louis en
una de enlace línea verdad y
esencialmente lo que obteníamos era esta
de aquí verdad teníamos el h y tres
líneas que convergen en un punto y
recordamos que estaban implícitos todos
los hidrógenos así que esencialmente con
esto contiene la misma información tanto
la estructura de louis como la
estructura de enlace línea verdad pero
obviamente es mucho más fácil y más
rápido dibujar la de enlace línea ahora
qué pasa con las estructuras de enlace
línea tridimensionales como podríamos
representar esta molécula en tres
dimensiones usando digamos una hoja de
papel plana aquí tengo una imagen de un
modelo que hice de esta misma molécula y
nos ayudará a dibujar la estructura de
enlace línea en tres dimensiones así que
empecemos con él
carbono del centro digamos empecemos con
este carbono que estoy circulando y que
representa esencialmente a este o este
otro carbono
y lo que podemos observar es que estos
dos enlaces que están digamos a un
costado de este átomo de carbono se
encuentran sobre la misma hoja o sobre
digamos el mismo plano verdad entonces
está en esta cuestión la vamos a
representar justamente poniendo nuestro
carbono tenemos nuestro carbono que
estar que es el del centro y vamos a
poner simplemente dos líneas digamos
sólidas que van a representar estos
enlaces cuando se encuentran en la
digamos en el mismo plano o en la misma
hoja de papel
entonces los vamos a pintar como líneas
sólidas muy bien ahora vamos a ver qué
ocurre por ejemplo por ejemplo con este
o h verdad o h el oxígeno está pintado
en rojo y el hidrógeno con blanco
entonces representa básicamente a este
conjunto verdad también representa a
este que tenemos aquí ahora algo que hay
que recordar es que
nuestro carbono digamos este carbono que
teníamos aquí tiene una geometría o más
bien tiene una hibridación sp3 verdad y
eso le da una geometría que trae drica
alrededor de él entonces lo que vamos a
estar observando y que de hecho se ve
aquí en la imagen es justamente esa esa
estructura geométrica de detraer muy
bien entonces si retomamos el en este
detalle con nuestro grupo o h o nuestro
conjunto o h
lo que podemos observar es que este
oxígeno en particular déjenme quizás
debería pintarlo con amarillo este
oxígeno en particular podemos ver que
está saltando hacia nosotros verdad de
hecho por eso es que se ve mucho más
grande se ve mucho más grande porque se
está digamos está saliéndose hacia
nosotros desde la hoja de papel en donde
se encontraba el carbono verdad entonces
el oxígeno que es el rojo por eso es que
se ve más grande y esto lo podemos
representar en nuestro dibujo digamos en
el plano con una cuña la cuña va a
representar que se está saliendo de la
hoja de papel o digamos se está
aproximando hacia nosotros el digamos el
hilo h verdad el oxígeno con el
hidrógeno muy bien ahora veamos qué pasa
con este este hidrógeno que tenemos
atrás del carbono verdad entonces eso
representa a este hidrógeno en la
estructura de louis o bien aquí en la
estructura de enlace línea
representado pero sabemos que está
implícitamente dicho que aquí hay un
hidrógeno verdad entonces pensemos
ahorita en este hidrógeno y que voy a
marcar con amarillo en nuestra figura ok
este hidrógeno de aquí este hidrógeno de
aquí a diferencia del oxígeno está
apuntando hacia atrás del plano verdad
este se está alejando de nosotros se
está alejando de nosotros entonces
cuando podemos observar esto en una
molécula lo vamos a representar con una
línea punteada entonces aquí del carbono
vamos a poner una línea punteada hacia
el hidrógeno y eso está indicando que se
está alejando de nosotros o bien que
está que el hidrógeno se encuentra
detrás del plano de la hoja de papel en
donde se encontraba el carbono entonces
solo para retomar un poco en lo que lo h
está apuntando hacia nosotros verdad se
está saliendo del plano entonces lo
ponemos o lo representamos con una cuña
mientras que el hidrógeno se está
alejando de nosotros o está yéndose
hacia atrás del plano en donde se
encuentra el carbono y eso lo
representamos con una línea punteada
ahora veamos qué pasa con el carbono que
se encuentra a la izquierda del carbono
central ok que es esencialmente este que
está representado en la estructura de
louis por este carbono y representaría
este punto en la estructura de enlace
línea por supuesto este carbono también
tiene una hibridación sp3 y por lo tanto
esperaríamos encontrar también una una
geometría tetra erika alrededor de él y
que nuevamente en la imagen se confirma
verdad entonces lo primero que podemos
notar es que nuevamente estos dos
enlaces el que conecta al carbono
central con este hidrógeno que sé que
estoy señalando esos dos enlaces se
encuentran en la misma hoja de papel o
en el mismo plano verdad entonces esto
simplemente lo representamos como
habíamos dicho con líneas sólidas porque
ya teníamos esta línea sólida y ahora
ponemos esta otra línea sólida
veamos qué otra cosa podemos notar es
más incluso todavía ya podemos poner
este hidrógeno verdad se encuentran
todos estos en el mismo plano es el
hidrógeno sería este que estoy
circulando que se encuentra frente a mi
palma ahora bien si nosotros nos fijamos
en este otro hidrógeno verdad ese otro
hidrógeno está apuntando hacia nosotros
está saliendo de la hoja de papel o del
plano verdad entonces eso lo
representamos con una cuña de hidrógeno
ésta estará digamos el enlace entre este
carbono y el hidrógeno estará
representado con una cuña mientras que
el hidrógeno que se encuentra detrás que
estoy tratando de marcar acá ok que está
detrás de mi dedo pulgar que está
justamente detrás del plano verdad
entonces eso lo representamos con una
línea punteada y ahí tenemos digamos la
estructura te trae drica alrededor de
este carbono ahora si nos vamos con el
carbono de la derecha del que habíamos
pintado con morado y que voy a pintar
que voy a marcar más bien con rojo ok
que representaría a este carbono o bien
en la estructura de enlace línea sería
este carbono que también tiene una
hibridación sp3 ahora bueno podemos ver
que este enlace lo voy a poner
con rojo este enlace y este otro enlace
se encuentran en el mismo plano verdad
entonces este carbono está unido al
carbono central que era morado y también
a un hidrógeno que se encuentran sobre
el mismo plano ahora bien si nos fijamos
en este otro hidrógeno de aquí ese está
apuntando hacia nosotros verdad se está
saliendo del plano entonces lo
representamos en la estructura de enlace
línea tridimensional con una cuña
mientras que este otro carbono perdón
este otro hidrógeno se encuentra hacia
atrás verdad entonces lo representamos
con una línea punteada así que ya hemos
dibujado todo y no tenemos que cuando
tenemos uno
con hibridación sp3 vamos a tener el
siguiente patrón vamos a tener dos
enlaces dos enlaces que se encuentran en
el mismo plano
vamos a tener una cuña es decir un
enlace que está apuntando hacia fuera
perdón hacia nosotros o hacia arriba del
plano donde se encuentra el carbono y
vamos a tener líneas puntea una línea
punteada verdad que representa que se
está que está representando un átomo que
se está yendo hacia atrás del plano de
la hoja de papel verdad
ese patrón vamos a tener siempre que
tengamos un carbono con hibridación sp3
verdad y esta es la forma de representar
la geometría te trae drica alrededor de
esos carbonos ahora bien a veces no se
pintan los hidrógenos en este tipo de
estructura es verdad entonces lo que
vamos a tener es algo muy similar a este
a esta estructura de enlace línea que
teníamos solo que vamos a indicar que el
h está saliendo de nuestro plano verdad
a la cuña para indicar que el h está
saliendo de nuestro plano y ese carbono
está unido a otros dos carbonos verdad y
aquí por supuesto en el carbono central
está implícito que tenemos un hidrógeno
que esencialmente se está yendo hacia
atrás verdad porque pues porque ya
teníamos dos líneas sólidas y una cuña
verdad y lo mismo podríamos decir de
estos otros dos carbonos verdad entonces
dibujar estructuras de enlace línea
tridimensionales es una habilidad muy
importante que hay que desarrollar en
química aquí quizás no es tan importante
ver que el bache que acabamos de pintar
se encuentra adelante de eso es por cómo
lo dibujé porque así así se ve en la
imagen que teníamos del lado izquierdo
pero a veces en química orgánica es
importante entender qué es lo que sale
hacia ti en el espacio y qué es lo que
se va hacia atrás y las estructuras de
enlace línea de tridimensionales nos
permiten visualizarlo ahora bien también
los modelos como el de la el de la
imagen también ayudan así que deberías
conseguir el equipo
a poder hacerlos pues te ayudará
muchísimo a lo largo de este curso del
lado izquierdo tenemos la estructura de
louis de la aceptó la verdad aquí
tenemos la estructura de louis de la
acetona y podemos convertirlo
rápidamente en una estructura de enlace
línea verdad podría podríamos hacerlo de
la siguiente forma tenemos el doble
enlace con el oxígeno que une a un
carbono que a su vez está unido a otros
dos carbonos y de hecho estos ya no se
ya no se escriben verdad e
implícitamente están dados el resto de
los hidrógenos ahora bien podrían poner
estas estos electrones estas parejas de
electrones vamos a dejarlos ahí así que
la pregunta ahora es cuál sería una
estructura de enlace línea para la
acetona en tres dimensiones y a la
izquierda a la izquierda tenemos un
modelo de esta molécula y espero que
puedas ver que los átomos que tenemos
digamos aquí estos tres carbonos con sus
hidrógenos con estos con estos
hidrógenos y también con el oxígeno
todas
todos estos átomos se encuentran en el
mismo plano de hecho tengo otra imagen
digamos de esta misma molécula sólo que
girada y lo que quiero que veamos es que
aquí digamos esta bolita blanca que es
el hidrógeno con este carbono que está
unido al carbono que está tapando el que
está tapado digamos con este otro
carbono y este hidrógeno así como con
este oxígeno se encuentran también en el
mismo plano y que voy a tratar de
esbozar aquí ese plano ese plano o esa
hoja digamos se encuentran sobre la
misma hoja verdad entonces este es un
intento de que puedan verlo desde
distintas perspectivas muy bien
así que con esto que hemos visto ya
podríamos intentar dibujar la estructura
de enlace línea en tres dimensiones
verdad porque todas estas se encuentran
en el mismo plano tendríamos entonces el
carbono central unido a dos carbonos a
los carbonos que a su vez están unidos
cada uno a un hidrógeno y el carbono
central tiene un doble enlace con el
oxígeno cierto entonces este es nuestro
primer intento para dibujar la
estructura de enlace línea en tres
dimensiones y algo que quiero notar
antes de continuar es que ocurre con el
carbono del centro es decir estamos
pensando en este en este carbono o bien
digamos este carbono que está acá atrás
escondido verdad casi no se ve entonces
este carbono tiene una hibridación sp2
verdad y eso lo podemos distinguir por
el doble enlace con el oxígeno entonces
este carbono tiene una geometría
tribunal- plana alrededor de él y por
eso es que podemos garantizar que ese
carbono
2 carbonos de un costado es decir este
de aquí y este de acá tienen están en el
mismo plano verdad lo mismo ocurre con
el oxígeno con el óxido
ok entonces qué pasa por ejemplo ahora
con el el carbono que tenemos a la
izquierda verdad correspondería a este
que dicho sea de paso tiene una
hibridación sp3 entonces este carbono
tiene dos enlaces que se encuentran en
el mismo en el mismo plano y que de
hecho ya los tenemos aquí representados
y por supuesto también tiene dos y dos
hidrógenos que uno está delante y otro
está detrás verdad esto podríamos verlo
de la siguiente forma verdad bueno aquí
está este hidrógeno que tenemos del lado
izquierdo ya está representado mientras
que los otros tenemos que representarlos
con cuña o con línea punteada verdad uno
de ellos apunta hacia hacia nosotros
verdad mientras que el otro apunta hacia
atrás digamos del plano verdad ahora
bien si nos fijamos en el carbono de la
derecha uno de ellos también
un hidrógeno que está unido a ese
carbono apunta hacia nosotros mientras
que el otro está apuntando
atrás verdad entonces tenemos que poner
nuevamente una cuña una cuña para este
hidrógeno y una línea punteada para el
otro hidrógeno una forma digamos de
identificarlos en esta digamos figura
rota da es que si nosotros estuviéramos
observando desde aquí desde aquí hacia
este plano tendríamos que hay dos
hidrógenos que apuntan hacia ese ojo
verdad aquí tendríamos uno de ellos y
otro de ellos mientras que y que de
hecho corresponden justamente a los que
tienen la cuña en nuestra estructura de
enlace línea tridimensional mientras que
tenemos otros dos que voy a poner con
verde que voy a enmarcar con verde que
están apuntando hacia atrás de este
plano verdad y que corresponden
justamente a los que tienen la línea
punteada así que espero que te haya
ayudado esto a visualizarlo mucho mejor
ahora bien para la acetona no tiene
mucho sentido dibujar toda la estructura
de la derecha verdad es muy complicado
en realidad
yo lo hice porque quería que tuvieras
más intuición sobre el arreglo
tridimensional y la hibridación sp2 y
sp3 verdad que por cierto el carbono
rojo también tiene una hibridación sp3
verdad entonces esto nos ayudará a
entender más sobre la geometría o el
arreglo tridimensional de esta molecular
pero en general sólo nos quedamos con la
estructura de enlace línea tradicional
verdad pero siempre es bueno practicar
la visualización en tres dimensiones y
entender todos estos conceptos antes de
seguir avanzando en química orgánica